we're looking at instagram page of mike
jones knife and tool you should check it
out
he get he uh andrew gave me a gift from
him
that
is a badass
a butcher knife
yours is the earth da da da is from if
way russia kipling yeah the story of
this knife is kind of interesting
perhaps to people where it was i was
coming out here to austin to meet with
lex and it was his birthday i want to
get him a gift but i didn't know what to
get him and i contacted this guy mike
jones that i learned about through joe
rogan because the first remember in the
old
um days of joe rogan when you go on the
episode afterwards you'd take a picture
with an object so it's like elon with a
flamethrower or people would have the
axe i picked up this um bushwhacker
hatchet thing
and i
was like i love this thing and and joe
said oh yeah you should check out mike
jones's work he does these beautiful
knives and so
then i
heard your episode with joe and you
recited a poem at the end it was right
after your grandmother died
and
there's a line in that poem from from if
that um mike engraved on that knife for
you so he makes these by by hand i love
scratch there's the old days
[Laughter]
before the podcast and that's the first
appearance that was the first time on
there and um it was a lot of fun um in
the old in the old studio in los angeles
and um
yeah mike makes these beautiful knives
and i have this in i just have a great
admiration for crafts people yeah so
yeah do you use it do you cut your your
one meal a day steaks i feel
are you taking it with you on your
travels exactly
i actually uh used to keep it on the
table but i thought it it really
intimidates guests a little bit
but like you put it on their side yeah
yeah right it's like oops
it's trust right
what's what's the story i mean yeah so
but it's because it's not
it's it's uh quite badass if i may say
so the craftsmanship is obvious but also
it is a knife
yeah it's got some like dexter like
qualities to it yeah it looks like it's
designed to to cleave through a limb if
i had like a family or something where
people there's nothing about this place
that softens your kind of
sense that this my
person might not murder me
let's put it differently uh this place
could use a woman's touch
that's one way to put it if it's okay
let me because it is it is a poem i
um
go go to often actually
uh you mentioned reciting some lyrics
and i'm actually gonna go back to that
at some point to get get a few songs
that touch you
um
but this is one of the things i i go too
often i i
i'll read it to remind myself it's um
advice from
from uh father to son
and it's a kind of mantra that it's just
nice to live by so if it's killing me
just use this opportunity one more time
read if by roger kipling
if you can keep your head when all about
your losing theirs and blaming it on you
if you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting to
if you can wait to not be tired by
waiting or being lied about don't deal
in lies
or being hated don't give way to hating
and yet don't look too good nor talk too
wise if you can dream and not make
dreams your master
if you can think and not make thoughts
your aim if you can meet with triumph
and disaster and treat those two
imposters just the same
if you can bear to hear the truth you've
spoken twisted by nays to make a trap
for fools or watch the things you gave
your life to broken
and stoop and build them up with worn
out tools
if you can make one heap of all your
winnings and risk it all
on one turn of pitch and toss
and lose and start again at your
beginnings
and never breathe a word about your loss
if you can force your heart to nerve and
sin you to serve your turn long after
they're gone
and so hold on when there's nothing in
you except the will which says to them
hold on
if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue i like this one and walk
with kings nor lose the common touch
if neither foes and their loving friends
can hurt you if all men count with you
but none too much
if you can fill the unforgiving minute
with 60 seconds worth of distance run
yours is the earth and everything that's
in it and which is more you'll be a man
my son
thank you andrew thank you thank you
mike for the knife it's a
i don't know it's a it's beautiful and
engraved in it
yeah it's yours yours is the earth and
everything that's in it
we toiled over what to engrave and then
finally i just said mike just
pick something that speaks to you you're
the craftsman and so he selected that
you